طرح نائب رئيس مجلس سياده السوداني مالك
عقار خريطه طريق لانهاء الازمه في البلاد
تقضي بوقف فوري للقتال واطلاق حوار يؤسس
لمرحله انتقاليه كما دعا عقار الدعم
السريع لادراك استحاله وجود جيشين بالبلاد
التي تنذر الاوضاع فيها بتوسع دائره
القتال من جانبه رفض الدعم السريع التعليق
على المبادره واعلن التمسكه بمنبر جده
للتفاوض مع الجيش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم توقيت وبنود
المبادره التي طرحها جاري ووصفها بمبادره
الحكومه وما الذي يعنيه طرحها مسارا
انتقاليا وهل تعد بديلا عن الاتفاق
الاطاري وما مدى تقاطع هذه المبادره مع
مبادرتي ايجاد ومسار جده لحل الازمه
السودانيه وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم موقف
الدعم السريع منها ما فرص نجاح المبادره
في التوصل لوقف لاطلاق النار يؤسس لمرحله
جديده بالنظر لتناقض ذلك مع اشتداد
المعارك وتزايد نذور توسعها الى جبهات
جديده
[موسيقى]
في اول ايام الشهر الخامس للحرب في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وغداه خطاب لرئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان كان فيها اغلط التهم لقياده قوات
الدعم السريع وتواعدها بالحسم متجاهلا اي
دعوه للحوار معها طرح نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده مالك عقار خريطه طريق تقوم على
وقف فوري للقتال وتدشين حوار شاملا يؤسس
لمرحله انتقاليه
تبدا خارطه الطريق بالتواصل لوقف اطلاق
نار بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريه المتمرده وتحديد مواقع تجميع قوات
الدعم السريع المتمرده بعيدا عن المناطق
المدنيه للفصل بين القوات والتزام بعدم
تعرض المواطنين لخطر الاقتتال وذلك حتى
تكتمل عمليه وضع اجراءات خارطه طريق
الترتيبات الامنيه لتلك القوات ويعقوب ذلك
بدايه العمليه الانسانيه بايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه للمواطنين في المناطق المتضرره
من الحرب كما سنقوم بالتركيز ايضا على
ضمان حياه طبيعيه بقدر الامكان للمواطنين
السودانيين
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوداني ومن واشنطن الدكتور ويليام
لورينز استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في الجامعه
الامريكيه والمسؤوله السابق في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون شمال افريقيا
سيد محمد تورشن ابدا معك تاتي مبادره عقار
بعد يوم واحد من خطاب كان لرئيس مجلس
السياده السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان كان فيه
الاتهامات للدعم السريع ولم يكن خطابا
تصالحيا في اي معنى من معانيه كيف يستقيم
المنطقه
في البدايه التحيه لك وكذلك للضيف الكريم
والساده المشاهدين الكرام انا في تقديري
الخطاب السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان وكذلك
خطاب لاعب رئيس مجلس السياده مالك عقار
يتفقان بعضهم البعض لا سيما من خلال
الحديث بشكل مباشر بان الدعم السريع ارتكب
انتهاكات وجرائم وفظائف حق المدنيين وان
كانت
اشارات السيد مالك عقار اقل حده من اشارات
السيد عبد الفتاح برهان التي وصف فيها
محمد حمدان بانه اليهود اكبر مؤامره
تستهدف امنه وحده وتماسك السودان لذا انا
في تقديري الموقفين بعضهم البعض بالرغم من
ان خطاب القران في حد ذاته يحمل في في
اتونه الكثير من الاشارات لقيالات الدعم
السريعه بانه
الاشارات تتحدث بانه يمكن قبول الدعم
السريع وهذا ما اشار له السيد مالك عقار
فقط بان يتم تجميعهم في نقاط معينه ومن
بعد دمجهم في الله في المؤسسه العسكريه
وانا في تقدير هذه الجزئيه هي التي فجرت
الخلاف ومعلومه تماما اذا تم تطبيق شروط
في المؤسسه العسكريه على القيادات العليا
مثل محمد حمدان دقله وشقيقه الى ذلك لا
يستوفون هذه الشروط وهذه هي انا في تقدير
الجزئيات التي اسهمت بشكل مباشر في اندلاع
هذه المواجهات وقد اشاره
ولكن سالت عن الاشارات التي ظهرت في خطاب
البرهان وكانت تشي بانها تتطابق مع ما
طرحه السيد مالك عجار
هي الجزئيات المرتبطه بضروره ان تكون
هنالك التسويه لكن لم يقولها برهان بشكل
مباشر لكن من خلال حده الخطاب الذي اعددنا
ان يظهر به البرهان كانت هذه الحده غير ما
غير معهوده في الخطاب الاخير فضلا عن ذلك
لغه الجسد كانت تعبر عن ذلك فضلا عن ذلك
هنالك جزيئات مهمه مرتبطه بسير العمليات
العسكريه والان ومنذ فتره حده العمليات
العسكريه في الخرطوم لم تكن لك السابق من
خلال استخدام المدفعيه وسلاح الطيران وما
الى ذلك كل هذه الامور تؤكد بان هنالك
رغبه جاده من قبل المؤسسه العسكريه وربما
الدعم السريع ايضا لديه نفس الرغبه لكن
فقدت الاختلاف في بعض التفاصيل في تقدير
مهمه جدا في توصيف ما حدث المؤسسه
العسكريه تعتبر ما حدث انقلاب عسكري في
الاتجاه الاخر الدعم السريع يعتبر انه
حدثوا عباره عن محاوله لاسترداد المسار
الديمقراطي اني اشرت الى ان المنطقان
يستقيمان وان كانت هنالك اشارات في خطاب
السيد البرهان اتوقف هنا على حول ما قاله
البرهان يعني وصف الدعم السريع بانه نفذ
اكبر عمليه غادر وخيانه وقال ان السودان
يتعرض بسبب الدعم السريع لاكبر مؤامره في
تاريخه الحديث وتوعد بالحسم العسكري الحسم
العسكري لا يتصق مع منطق المبادرات اليس
كذلك
اذا كان السؤال لي انا في تقدير الحزم
العسكري اوكي اذا كان الحزم العسكري
المقصود به هو الحزم العسكري من خلال
المواجهات العسكريه وما الى ذلك فهذا
الامر في الخطابات السابقه للبرهان كان
الحديث بضروره الحسم العسكري وما الى ذلك
بشكل واضح وبشكل صريح لكن في خطاب البرهان
الاخير والذي يعلم خطابات البرهان جيدا
هذا الخطاب فيه نوع من الرسائل وفيه نوع
من التبطين الرسائل المهمه جدا وانا في
تقديري اظهار حرب اذا كان والطرق السلميه
او الطرق العسكريه في النهايه النتيجه
واحده وهي الاشاره التي اشار اليها مالك
عقار وهي ضروره ان يكون هنالك جيش واحد
وهنا مربط الفرس في تقديره اذا تم حزم
المعرفه عسكريا ايضا سيكون هنالك جيش واحد
واذا تم حزمه دبلوماسيه ايضا سيكون هنالك
جيش واحد فبالتالي انا في تقدير الان هي
المبادره هي ولدت ميته باي حال من الاحوال
لا نتجاوز نقطه مدى اتساقها مع ما قاله
السيد البرهان ونستمع من السيد لورنس سيد
لورينز انتم كيف قراتم هذه المبادره وجاءت
بعد يوم واحد من خطاب للسيد البرهان كاد
فيه يعني الكثير من الاتهامات للدعم
السريع
انا
تاكدت من وزاره الخارجيه ولكنهم قالوا
انهم ليس لديهم تعليق حتى الان
اعتقد انني على وفاق مع الضيف الاخر في
تحليلاته البرهان حتى اللحظه لم يقم بدور
جيد بقدر يتعلق الامر بالتعري المواقف
والدبلوماسيه وما الى ذلك لا اعتقد انه
القى خطابا بمثل كلمه او مبادره عقار ما
قاله عقار هو
يختلف عن
خطاباتي البرهان البرهان رجل العسكري وليس
سياسي مبادره عقار نحن نرحب بها ووزاره
الخارجيه اطلعتني على انها خطوه تقنيه
جيده لاننا هذا كان التعليقا خاصا بيني
وبين الوزاره لكن جيد ان كلا ان يحترم
اتفاقات او تفاهمات جدا لنعود الى عمليه
تفاوضيه مبادره عقار جيده هي اعتقد انها
لم تكن استجابه لما قاله البرهان بل ما
قدمه حمدتي قبل ذلك ربما قد لا تؤدي الى
نتيجه لكن على الاقل لدينا شيء مطروح على
الطاوله وجيد ان الحكومه السودانيه ترد
سلام لم ترى بان خطاب البرهان كما يقول
السيد محمد توشين حمل اشارات تمهد لهذه
المبادره
نعم نعم هذه النقطه التي انا اقول البرهان
عاده يرسل اشارات لكن ليس بالوضوح التي
الوضوح الذي يجب ان يكون عليها لهذا السبب
انا لم اختلف مع اي شيء قال له الضيف
واتفق معه ولكن انا اريد من الحكومه او
احد منها ان تكون اكثر وضوحا واعتقد ان
عقار قام بذلك وهنا تحرك افضل باتجاه حل
الخلاف اعود اليك سيد تورشين سيد تورشين
يعني قبل ما نتحدث عن مولوده هذه بنود هذه
المبادره بشكل موسع السيد عقار قال انه
استعرض وناقش بنود المبادره مع قوى سياسيه
ومدنيه ومع عالميين ومواطنين في الخارج هل
نفهم ان الحكومه السودانيه اتخذت وقتها
لتعد هذه المبادره هل تمثل هذه
المبادره رؤيه الحكومه للحل
انا في تقديري وحسب المعلومات المتوفره من
خلال تصريحات السيد مالك عقارك كذب انه
هنالك خط للتواصل الساخن والخاص بينه وبين
السيد البرهان على طوال الفجر التي قضاها
بالخارج وهنالك بعضها التسريبات التي
صدرتها لقاءات كانت حديثه ومهمه بينه وبين
عدد من قيادات القوى السياسيه سواء كان في
الكتله الديمقراطيه او المجلس المركزي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير او بعض الشخصياتها
علمنا ذلك من مصادر
مختلفه وحتى من بعض الشخصيات التي التقاها
لكن في تقدير الان باي حال من الاحوال
التحدي بيتمثل في امكانيه تطبيق هذه
المبادره على ارض الواقع لاسيما ان هنالك
فصيل مهم جدا وهو المجلس المركزي الحريه
والتغيير بينها وبين هذه المبادره نقطه
جوهريه ومهمه توصيف ما حدث المبادره توصف
ما حدث هو بمثابه انقلاب عسكري او محاوله
للانقلاب العسكري ومن بعد تحولت الى تمرد
وفي الاتجاه الاخر وبالتغيير الى ذلك تحدث
عن جرائم حرب قام بها الدعم السريع اشار
بان ما كان يطرحه الدعم السريع في بدايه
ما قام به ضغط عليه جرائم الحرب ولكنه لم
يتحدث عن انقلاب الا يصب ذلك في مصلحه ما
يقولون بان هنالك اكثر من مركز قرار داخل
الحكومه او السلطه في السودان
والتحدث بان تمرد واكد ذلك في خطابه في
مرات عده وهذا الاخير
في الخطاب الاخير تحدث عن ماليزيا الدعم
المتمرد الدعم السريعه المتمرد ويمكن
للساده في القناه يراجع ذلك يعني
لا تحدث عن تمرد وليس انقلاب ولكن
الانقلاب جاء في سياق في سياق قالمه
التمرد باعتبار ان الهدف كان الاستيلال
السلطه من بعد تحول الى تمرد انا فهمت هذا
الخطاب بهذه الجزئيات وبهذه التفاصيل لكن
انا في تقدير الجزئيه المهمه والتي اشرت
اليها بان فعلا هنالك مراكز مختلفه في صنع
القرار داخل الدوله السودانيه او اجهزه
الدوله السودانيه وهذه هي معلومه تماما
نتيجه للتناقضات ونتيجه لطبيعه وشكل
الحكومه
الانتقاليه وكذلك الحكومه التي تم تشكيلها
بعد انقلاب اكتوبر 2021 وهذا امر معلوم
تماما باعتبار ان الخطاب الذي ادنى به
السيد مالك عقاب اثار حفيظه الكثير من
الذين يستنفروا وشعركوا مع قوات المسلحه
وعبسطونا النظام البارد باعتبار ان هذا
الخطاب ووجه لهم نقض في تجربتهم السابقه
وما الى ذلك وفي الاتجاه الاخر هنالك ايضا
مجموعات داخل المؤسسه العسكريه ترفض هذا
الخطاب
بمثابه
اعطاء الدعم السريع اكثر مما يستحقه ضروره
ان يكون الحسم حسب العسكريا لكن انا في
تقديرهم
تماما الاته تداعيات الحرف لديه تجربته
السياسيه الثاره التي تؤهلها
اكثر من مركز الاتخاذ القرار تحدثت عن قوى
داخل الجيش تعتبر بان هذا او هذه المبادره
اعطت الدعم السريع اكثر من ما
يحق له ولكن هل هل تاتي هذه المبادره
بتناغم مع مواقف السيد البرهان يعني هل هو
راض بتقديرك عن هذه المبادره
انا في تقدير البرهان في شخصه وهو راضي
تماما ويزعل بشكل او باخر لتسويه هذا
الامر لان حتى القرارات المرتبطه بمطارده
قيادات الدعم السريعه والمداعونين معهم في
الاتجاه القضائي حتى الان لم تتحرك بالشكل
الكافي حتى عزل محمد حمدان دقله من موقعه
كنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وكذلك اعلام قوات
الدعم السريع بانها قوات متمرده وما الى
ذلك لم تاتي بالسرعه والاستجابه والقزوه
فبالتالي هذا ما يؤكد بان السيد البرهان
لديه شيء او لديه ظل دائما يترك الباب
مواربا حتى يستطيع من خلاله التوصل الى
تفاهمات لكن هنالك رتب وسيطه وكذلك قيادات
عليا في الجيش السوداني تفضل الخيار
العسكري وهنا تضمر المشكله هنا في تقدير
باعتبار ان البرهان يعمل منذ فتره بعيده
انه يحاول ان يرضوا الطرفين او يرضي كافه
التيارات داخل المؤسسه العسكريه وكذلك
التيارات السياسيه الامر الذي اسهم بشكله
باخر في تفجر الاوضاع بشكل
دكتور ويليام لورنس يعني اذا ما دخلنا الى
بنود هذه
المبادره البند الاول هو وقف اطلاق النار
ولكن هل استشفيتم من خلال هذه المبادره ان
هنالك اطار او كيفيه لتنفيذ وقف اطلاق
النار كيف سيتم ذلك من خلال الطلب مباشره
من خلال حوار يعني كيف يمكن ان نصل الى
هذه النتيجه
اعتقد ان كل عمليات تحقيق السلام اذا كانت
التي في جده او ايجاد كلها لديها هدف واحد
وفيه مكون يتعلق
بهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار وحوار سياسي
والقضيه تعتمد على من وكيف تتم هذه
الترتيبات بامكاننا ان نفترض بعض الامور
وفقا لاي من هذه الاتفاقات لكن ينبغي ان
تتم وتبحث بشكل مسبق احسى العقبات المهمه
هنا طبعا
كل الطرفين يحاولوا محو قياده الطرف الاخر
وهكذا دواليك اذا اذا ما اردنا ان نصل الى
اي شيء علينا ان نتحدث عن تغيير في
القيادات المستقبل وليس فورا في هذا
النقاش نقطه
المهمه في كلمه عقار تفيد بانه حتى لان
حمايه تحدث عن الديمقراطيه بكلام معسول
وجيد وعن بعض اهدافه هو ليس له الحق هو
منافق بسبب جرائم الحرب التي ارتكب هذه
نقطه ممتازه اذا كنت ديمقراطيا وكنت تحب
السلام لو كانت قواتك تغتصب وتقتل وتغزو
البيوت وترتكب جرائم حرب اكثر من الطرف
الاخر عليك ان ترتب اوضاع بيتك في الداخل
قبل ان تصبح شريكا في السلام هل ترى بان
هذه المبادره تتقاطع مع مسار جدا لان دعم
السريع يتمسك فقط بمسار جده
مره اخرى ان الامر لا يتعلق بماذا بل بمن
مسار جده مهم لان الامريكان كقوع عالميه
والسعوديه كقوه اقليميه ممكن ان تدعم اي
مسار وايضا داخل المنظومه ايجاد ايضا التي
تبدو خطه بديله هناك خلافات بين الخرطوم
وكينيا وقعدتها مثلا اما ايضا من عندما
تقترحوا في قبل شهر ان تكون هناك منطقه
حظر جوي هذه لا امل لها في ان تتحقق لان
القوه
العسكري السوداني الوحيده التي تملك سلاح
طيران وهكذا ايضا ايا كانت مسارات السلام
القاهره او تشاد او غيرها سواء التقت مع
هذه المبادره او لا نامل في ان ما قاله
عكار سيكون طريقا الى الامام لكن من
الافضل ان تتم ضمن اطار جده طيب انت تتحدث
عن اطار جده كذلك فعل الدعم السريع الذي
دعاها عقار الى ادراك استحاله وجود جيشين
في البلاد بعد الان وندد بما سماها
انتهاكاته رفض التعليق على المبادره التي
قدمها عقار بل وهدد بنقل المعارك الى
الولايات لكنه اكد تمسكه بمساج جده
للتفاوض مع الجيش
نحن ملتزمين بمنبره جده وحتى الان وفدنا
موجود في منبر جدبه المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه وندعو لتوحيد كافه المبادرات
نلتقي الاتحاد الافريقي نلتقي لايجاد
نحاول توحيد كل المبادرات وهذا طرحنا انه
كل المبادرات تتوحد قبل المبادرات نفسها
لابد ان يتوحد السودانيين على الحل الشامل
هذه هي المساله
سيد ترشين اذا الدعم السريع يحدد بنقل
المعركه الى الولايات كيف تنظرون الى هذا
التهديد
او هو منذ فتره طويله وظل الدعم السريع
ينقل الحرب هو فعلا الان الحرب في دارفور
في كردفان كذلك في الخرطوم الان مساله دعم
السريع لنقلها الى الى ولايه الجزيره ومن
بعدي الى الشمال السودان ممثل في ولايه
نهر النيل ومن بعد الى شق السودان هكذا هو
المخطط وربما نتيجه الان لبعض العوامل
وبعض التفاصيل ربما ينجح في ذلك لان يبدو
ان هنالك الدعم السريع انه يؤسس لشبكه
جيده من
الحلفاء سواء كان داخل اجهزه الدوله كان
في المؤسسه العسكريه فيديو في دواوين
الخدمه المدنيه وما الى ذلك فبالتالي هذا
التحديث لاحظناه من خيارات حتى لديها
علاقات مع الدعم اتوقع انه النطاق الحربي
سيتسع واتزاع النطاق الحرب يعني بشكل او
باخر مع ان السودان الان اصبح مهدد تماما
هو ربما يعني ذلك انهيار الدوله السودانيه
ودخولها في حرب مفتوحه
متى ستنتهي فبالتالي اعرفي تقديري الامر
مبادره السيد مالك عقار ربما لا تجد
الاستجابه الكامله الشامله لكن ينبغي
للساده في منبر جده المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه ان
يعني تاخذ بعض الحيثيه او بعض الجزيئات
المهمه جدا المتمثله ففي هذه الخارطه
الطريق المتمثل اولا في قضيه وقف اطلاق
النار مرهونه بتحديد نقاط لتجمع قوات
الدعم السريعه توفيق ضبعانات وعدم
الاعتداء عليها سواء الطيران او المدفعيه
الجزئيه الثانيه وهي اجراء حوار الشامل
بين كل القوه السياسيه السودانيه باستثناء
الحزب الذي سقط او الحزب الحاكم سابقا
الحزب المؤتمر الوطني والمرحله الثالثه
يعني قبل المرحله الثالثه عفوا على
المقاطعه ولكن تتحدث عن حوار شامل ايضا
فعل عقار هل يعني ذلك بان هذا الحوار هو
بديل عن الاتفاق الايطالي وبالتالي اذا تم
وقف اطلاق النار هل سنعود الى نقطه الصفر
انا في تقديري الاتفاق الايطالي انتهى
بذراع هذه الحرب وقوع الحريه والتغيير هي
تعلم بذلك تماما ولا حديث عن الاتفاق
الاداري ما كالسابق لان الجيش الذي الان
يحارب الدعم السريع والدعم السريع الذي
يحارب الجيش وما كان طرفين في الاتفاق
الايطالي وهنالك قضايا ملحه في الاتفاق
الاطار في تقدير اسهمك بشكل مباشر في
تغيير هذه الاوضاع اللي هي متمثله في قضيه
دم جلايه الجيش الدعم السريع في الجيش
السوداني والخيول الزمنيه لذلك وكذلك قضيه
الاداره والسيطره التي قطعتها قبل ان
تذكرها
بتقدير النقطه الثالثه والمهمه هي تشكيل
حكومه من الكفاءات الوطنيه غير المنتميه
حزبيا وان تكون هنالك فتره انتقاليه لا
تتجاوز العمل العام الاول يتم فيها دمج كل
الجيوش الحركات المسلحه والدعم السريع وان
تجرى فيها انتخابات التشريعيه حتى يكون
هنالك تطويل جماهيري للبرلمان وفي
الانتهاء
يحتاج الى حلقه جديده من سيشكل الحكومه
وكيف سيتم دمج الدعم السريع ولكن على كل
الاحوال لدي سؤال اخير للسيد لورنس البيت
الابيض قال ان واشنطن تتحرك لوقف القتال
في السودان وانه حان الوقت لطرفي من اجل
القاء اسلحتهم وتنفيذ اراده الشعب هل يحمل
هذا الموقف اي جديد وهو جاء بعد يوم من ما
طرحه عقار
كلا هذا مجرد اعاده توصيف لان الولايات
المتحده
ايدت الحمل الثوره الاصليه في 2019 هذه
مجرد اعاده
للبيان السابق تذكروا ان الحرب بدات في
الشمال في ذلك المطار ثم بعد ذلك انتقلت
الى مناطق اخرى
القتال الحقيقي اقتصر على
دارفور وكردفان والخرطوم
ايضا مقترح برلمان جديد من عقار لا امله
في التحقيق الفكره دكتور ويليام شكرا لك
دكتور ويليام لورنس استاذ العلاقات
الدوريه في الجامعه الامريكيه والمسؤول
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون
شمال افريقيا كنت معنا من واشنطن ومن
باريس محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوداني
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]